professore en la facultad que continúa
mentum amitaba salir
it's an emotional outpouring on this
wall in Mexico State University female
students reporting professors students
and even relatives that they say have
harassed or attacked them over years
Mexico's Attorney General has said that
more than ten women are killed a day but
behind the number some say is a culture
of machismo male chauvinism which in the
end helps lead to the violence around 20
professors just from Mexico State
University and now under investigation
this student is one of those who
complained there's boys come in so calm
paranthas man he started asking me are
you a virgin what have you done with
your boyfriend have you done naughty
things his conduct is normalized enough
in society she says that she didn't know
who to turn to
Brenda yo yo give me you go answers men
so he's missing when I saw his messages
I felt alone I didn't know who to talk
to in my family or in the police or the
student committees even my boyfriend who
I asked for help just accused me of
starting at all the submissive
objectified woman is a current that runs
through popular culture in Mexico these
are the weather reporters of a 24-hour
news channel
and it's a constant on the countries all
popular telenovelas says screenwriter
Annie Lupardo embrace Turia's only
always seeing storylines in which the
women are victims are hysterical
bossy and annoying convinces is all that
yes women are annoying and bossy and
sensitive when they're having their
period and it's not true but in the last
year more and more women have been
rejecting how they're seen and the
violence against them through protests
and even street monuments like this one
it's actually being cleaned in advance
of a March that's going to go through
Mexico City's main avenue this Sunday to
mark International Women's Day on Monday
there will also be a National Women's
strike this movement is only gaining
traction John Holman al Jazeera Mexico
City